[Music]
you said to my face that you never
turned into the abomination anymore no i
said i choose not to you know these were
extenuating circumstances you understand
that this constitutes another crime and
totally destroys your chances at parole
well
no cause
i was forced
to leave my cell but i returned
of my own free will who forced you to
escape this insanely high security
prison undetected a sorcerer supreme of
the mystic arts and his name is
wong just
wong and his internet presence is a
little chaotic he's either a sorcerer
who lives in new york or a librarian who
lives in nepal can you get to him yes
jen it's me of course i can get to him i
sent a thirst trap
it was a picture of me with a bunch of
books i just hope that he calls back you
know if blonsky's telling the truth this
guy busted him out of his prison cell
and probably ruined my entire case
who the hell are you jennifer walters
attorney at law
jen this is your life now whether you
like it or not trouble's gonna find you
let's do this
you could be an avenger i'm not a
superhero that is for billionaires and
narcissists
and adult orphans for some reason
she-hulk attorney at law original series
streaming august 18th only on disney
plus
[Music]
bye